hey youtubers this is Charlie this is
gonna be my game of Thrones tell tell
gameplay
I'm gonna upload at least to have these
first videos on this channel
and then I'll upload the rest to my
bonus channel saw have links to that in
the description
I have a game challenges called Charlie
streams so please enjoy
overall there's about two hours or so
worth the gameplay per episode
this is gonna be episode 1 so they'll be
like four or five videos this I just
breaking up in like 15 minutes jugs
just remember too that it's all taken
from the end of season three
to the beginning a season five
King
wrote to me ni
min this is picking up three
like rated the into the red wedding I
think they're red wedding is
like happening right now all the great
the end a season 3
itself
make sure it's Paul is this time
forrester will be happy with blood and
brains old
go on only blood
profits soared Aloe Blacc yourself
someday
you nervous or like I say that as a
friend
if we're being honest justice
Ryan I'll you'll see
you'll see moise lordship up to you
take your rightful place on the island
up wats
June he was nowhere near the Kings
leonid
was drug-dealing first-hand next
tell us he got teary to think he's done
never lets the truth stand in the way of
a good story
you capture Kings ok
but build
forrester breakup
questioning our on questioning
stop more every time itself
up elite World some wine
go on
job but thanks gump
thank you cap
Lawrence family faithfully serve house
hardest
percentage his honor is beyond reproach
house tony is forever and it's stacked
never seem to be
out show where a city the Kingslayer
track
partner across the bottom he was
actually involved in a cashmere Jaime
Lannister
then he really does help caliente stark
picture night police
but these are none of these characters
were featured on the show
so like any when you see in the game is
completely original to this game
but they do flow from the original
source material object you know our
the march on
cost rock house honestok has been given
the greatest gonna
lead Tommy ride
this isn't going to end well for anyone
in his army it
are from ice
is just a if this house is motto
PG to keep Rowntree a cease-fire
I could not be more proud them speak
roderick is like the Robb Stark
as this house the four search house
crappy
just 10 is also the question you
I'm what do you mean
use douse forest well several years
can't expect you to Squire have a how
shall I reward your
ok I'll well
let me fight you know all who
ability Oman question bored or sorrow
member that
when you don't click but for your names
my school you've arranged
time it would be an honor to see you
riding
Rodricks side in the back not as esquire
but as the equal of any man who serves
hopes for hope he doesn't offer me a
seat
at the Red Wedding your hard work
like humanoid I promise award
right in front of Walder Frey but for
now keep this between
celebrate will be on the Squires
will discourage yes my lord gold
find roderick I will thank you
so I'm using the mouse but you can
actually use your a X boxer
ps4 controller with this on the Steam
version give me a hand
up to you
yep a plate is lawful good the first
time through
you so thank you should help
line
Obama booze just my luck
Lauren infectious on
want drunk liar and the American
free watch it on
could be much ON March about it nothing
this that's we look
all expectations shit chillin slop
maybe i'd fixed at least greatest on
their the Seven Kingdoms
I suppose is beat pig farm in up
not by much
this is a job pig farmer harlem's
at this rate we'll never be more than
this
just nothin' lowest the law all I know
peace most this game is supposed to take
place up in deep with mod
fuckin with fucking give it time
you'll get there that's where though
wats what is
house Glover actually controls most to
that
feel different my uncle is nothing to do
with it how much
other it's right over there
Redway up
take you to up
that does not look like from the person
jet good
world is chairs he may be the one to the
phrase
Prince that bucket very nice nighter
ready
he finds it weird and get tingly feeling
home expect me to carry
voice again was wrong
yeah I think
its most platforms at least by tomorrow
and they're actually releasing like an
Android version of it so I should be
able to play on mobile to
acting rather rock you need to get back
right now now in a good way
he'd just meet disc quietly
back aways tests link into the night
what's wrong with him something the
matter
boy we have to call actually right now
Aria stark in the counter probably
riding around in the background
somewhere
I'll
the warnings I
sorry buddy
home
and make the hard call
that's a good question like if you could
save Robb Stark
for arias star which one will you save
because you use a prop start may be able
to marshal the army
re-start is a really important character
K
red
you area
what happened when you use the mouse the
keyboard for game design
for x-box controller
ok
think that
well their upstart ideal
God
draw track
speak see more not
he's got a little there was nothing I
could do
mysqli so in this alternate timelines it
starts the one survives
%um big boy hop
I know what quickly
ok
few
track go my own
bombing still time
we have to keep moving on as a gun
everybody
talks
these the time
still intact Paul
art
have to call aboard Navy and you will
long time March you will a baby that can
remember it for very long because he
looks like he's gonna die
tell your uncle 10 of
most no
he'd you understand you must weigh tell
only your own called ok
future house done ice hell
there must always be a start in
Winterfell call
you must do its free house ok
forest if you guys actually watch season
for the
the whole 10 for actually marching on
Winterfell last time we saw them in
season four so
season 5 there will be some more
Winterfell
I'm achievement unlocked
is as the prologue
they talked about it during season 1 but
the same company that
did add the interest sequence for Rome
on HBO did the intro for this
so if you like like this Model Look
you should check out their room series I
mean it became unwell on time ago but
is really good TV show thanks so much
for watching this point in the game
played so
I'm gonna upload part 2 to my bonus
channel now
and then every video after that to that
game channel although every once in a
while I might stick one on this channel
just for fun
this actually was inspired by the card
game or any though the role playing in
that the card game
and you can click on these links to get
to the other videos
try to upload everything by the end it
tonight I'll be streaming in tonight too